[Music]
anyone can see that Merida of dunbroch
sticks out like a sore thumb when
standing next to the other Disney
Princesses wreck-it Ralph too is
scheduled to hit the big screen in late
2018 and judging from this trailer it
looks like the princesses have it out
for the first Pixar princess stick
around to find out why Merida is
breaking all of the rules don't forget
to subscribe to the things if you love
staying up to date with the latest
Disney news give us a big thumbs up and
more awesome videos will come your way
now let's find out why Princess Merida
is getting roasted left right and center
just six years before the movie brave
came out in theatres Walt Disney Studios
decided to join forces with Pixar the
house of mouse bought Pixar and has been
working alongside it ever since Merida
became an official Disney princess back
in 2013 however she isn't like the rest
of the women in the group did you catch
the latest record Ralph - trailer if so
you probably notice how the Disney
Princesses were throwing some shade
Merida sway while she might not have
done anything to warrant this her
differences make her easy to pick on as
soon as the brave star begins to speak
the princesses around her stare at her
in disbelief
vanellope von schweetz his jaw
practically hits the floor and princes
on a whispers she's from the other
studio while looking apologetic while
Merida might not get the joke it's quite
obvious that she's having some issues
with communicating
her incredibly thick accent makes it
impossible to understand her pure mace I
don't know way which is why many of us
hope that she'll have some subtitles in
the movie did any of you understand what
she said the first time around if so let
us know what you think you heard in the
comments and we'll reveal what she
really said at the end of this video
despite the fact that Merida isn't much
loved Disney Princess she's also the
first Disney Pixar princess to join the
group this makes her different than the
other girls in the dressing-room top
that off with her brute ways and it's
easy to see that the Disney Princesses
just don't know what to do with her on
top of all this the Disney Princesses
might be a little jealous of her
background after all hers is the
opposite of what they had to go through
by now we've seen the same tire plot
over and over again
girl feels lost girl meets boy boy saves
girl and they live happily ever after if
you're anything like us you're a little
sick and tired of these types of
storylines for centuries this is the
plot production Disney has been made to
follow
however after 2012's brave came out the
enchanted era ended with Pixar in its
back pockets at only 15 years old Merida
was being talked into marrying her
betrothed however the last thing she
wanted to do was get married nope our
girl Merida wanted to be as free as a
bird the fact that Merida is the first
Disney princess who doesn't have a
husband is a major deal it's obvious
that Disney is trying to shake up the
norm by giving us something other than a
love story to watch this may be a little
frustrating for the other Disney
Princesses as they were made to marry
from very early on look at Snow White
she got married at 14 years old no
wonder she's bitter for the time being
it looks like Merida might stay single
for the rest of her life and there's
nothing wrong with that on another notes
Merida also has something that the other
princesses crave a huge family have you
ever wondered why Disney Princesses tend
to be raised by single fathers or evil
stepmothers well we have to so allow us
to clear this up for you out of the
eleven Disney Princesses on record only
three of them have mothers of their own
Mulan Tiana and Merida have managed to
be raised by women which might have
given them the strength they needed to
follow their hearts the real reason for
this reoccurring theme however has
everything to do with Walt Disney and
nothing to do with his princesses you
see Walt Disney was traumatized by his
own mother's passing which prompted in
the past his pain onto his characters
obviously things needed to change which
is why many of the new princesses are
starting to have both their parents
present the fact that Merida had both
her mother her father and a bunch of
siblings is quite astonishing though
actually it's a first as a result of
this some Disney Princesses might feel
the need to roast their Scottish member
after all she doesn't know what growing
up alone feels like don't think this is
a good enough reason to roast someone
wait until you hear the last one on this
list when you think about Disney movies
you think about singing and dancing
rights well we hope you didn't get your
hopes up when watching brave because
singing and
don't exist in this movie it is common
knowledge that every single Disney
princess has the voice of an angel
however Merida never let her pipe shine
bright like a diamond this leads us to
believe that she's either a terrible
singer or she just doesn't like spending
her time bursting into song we're under
the impression that the Disney
Princesses like to roast Merida for her
awful voice in the end these ladies
probably enjoy sharing a song or two
behind the scenes and she probably gets
left out 100% of the time so why is it
that Merida refrains from singing a
single notes for the entirety of brave
the reason behind this is quite simple
the girl doesn't want to sing
Disney has been changing the rules for
quite some time now but having a song
this movie it's quite absurd well you
disappointed when you found out that
singing and dancing had no place in
brave if so just know that you're not
the only one so the moment we've all
been waiting for is here we're finally
going to find out what merit is said in
the wreck-it Ralph 2 trailer the Disney
Pixar princess says the following
I gave me mummy a cake she turned into a
big bear my old Yin tried to do her in
and if that's not a pure mess I don't
know what is after seeing the look on
Penelope's face they want to tells her
that they can't understand her either
and on a chimes in that she's from
another studio this Disney Pixar joke is
definitely hilarious Meredith's thick
Scottish accent is impossible to
decipher which will make her a hilarious
character in wreck-it Ralph - and who
knows maybe we'll hear her singing for
the first time and get blown away with
so many Disney Princesses to choose from
picking a favorite can seem impossible
if you had to choose one know which one
would it be let us know who your
favorite princess is in the comments and
be sure to tell us what makes her so
special to you and that concludes why
our
Merida is getting roasted by her fellow
princesses thanks for watching see you
next time
[Music]